oh it's so pretty
dem Deluxe
don't roll why even bother if I know
that all its gonna end in failure
that's all honky how many baby
yeah half um see what can I add
I could add oh that's so cool
this is Devon this is Devon let's blow
something up here oh my god oh it was
like three seconds long but it was like
the best three seconds of my life just
like the first time I had everyone
anyway oh oh it's so pretty
okay I can arrange objects in a solar
system but this is blowing my mind right
now
scalpels over on the right yes you pick
those up with your forefinger and your
thumb okay very delicate very tough not
telling you do do now you want to kill
me Oh run swim all right scared